يترقب ملايين الامريكيين والعالم محاكمه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
نيويورك اليوم شرطه نيويورك قصتها اكثر من
30 الف شرطي بلباس رسمي وتسعه عشر الف
اخرين بلباس مدني لتامين هذه المحاكمه
التاريخيه
راسها القاضي اخوان ميرشان الذي قرر عدم
بث المحاكمه على الهواء وسمح فقط باخذ
باخذ صور ثابته لترامب قبل بدء اجراءات
المحاكمه
واستعدادا لمحاكمته المقرره اليوم مصر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
قادما من فلوريدا ووفقا للاعلام الامريكي
رحله ترامب بدات بمغادره منزله في بالام
بيتش وصولا الى برج ترامب في منهات في
نيويورك وبعدها سيصل الى محكمه منهات
وسيواجه الاستدعاء في اول لائحه اتهام
لرئيس الامريكي سابق عند الثانيه وخمسه
عشره دقيقه بتوقيت المحلي اي 18 والربع
بتوقيت جرينتش بعد الانتهاء سيغادر
الترامب نيويورك عائدا الى فلوريدا تحديدا
الى مقره
وسيعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا عند الثامنه وخمسه
عشره دقيقه عند منتصف الليل بتوقيت
[موسيقى]
من نيويورك من امام محكمه من هاتن تحديدا
تنضم الينا مديره مكتبه مكتب العربيه
البلبيسي مرحبا ناديه يوم تاريخي في
الولايات المتحده وفي نيويورك تحديدا هي
المدينه ربما التي جعلت التي قفزت بترام
الى الساحه العالميه وظل العقود او ظلت
العقود جزءا لا يتجزا من تاريخ هذا الرجل
لكنها اليوم تقضيه وتحاكم في منظر مختلف
الاجراءات كيف ستتم
اهلا بك يا خالد بالفعل هي محاكمه تاريخيه
لرئيس جدلي وبطاقيه اعلاميه غير مسبوقه
على الاطلاق طبعا الجميع هنا بعدسات
الكاميرات تنتظر دخول الرئيس ترامب للاسف
لن نراه لانه سيدخل من باب خلفي ولن يكون
هناك تغطيه مرئيه لهذه المحاكمه بطلب من
القاضي رغم ان محامي الشاهد الاكثر ربما
شهره وهو مايكل كوين الذي كان يعمل مع
ترامب ودخل السجن من اجل ترامب والبعض راب
انه كان كبش فداء له كان يامل ان يكون
بالفعل هناك تغطيه اعلاميه متلفزه حتى يرى
الامريكيين ماذا سيحدث لكن عن كل الاحوال
اريد ان اركز على ان هذه ليست بمحاكمه هذه
بدء اجراءات بمعنى بان الرئيس ترامب سيدخل
مع الشرطه السريه طبعا انه رئيس سابق
يتمتع بهذه الخدمه حسب الدستور الامريكي
سيقول بانه غير عندما يتم فتح هذا الملف
ونستمع او سنعرف لاحقا لن نستمع لكن سنقرا
مع هذه الاتهامات التي نتوقع ان تكون اكثر
من 30 اتهاما لكن سنرى اذا كانت هناك
مفاجات يعني البعض يرى بانه المدعي العام
البراك يجب ان يكون لديه قضيه قويه جدا
حتى يستطيع القاضي بالفعل ان يقول يمكن ان
نستمر بالمحاكمه والا بامكان القاضي حتى
اليوم ان يقول بانه لا يوجد هناك ادله
قويه او ادله كافيه وبالتالي يغلق هذه
القضيه طبعا الرئيس ترامب سيستغل هذا طلب
طبعا من محاميه ان لا يكون هناك تقييد
لاداه وحتى الصوره التي تتخذ عادل الاشخاص
الذين يتهمون بجرائم قد لا ياخذها ويتسمى
لانه بتعرف هي حتى يعرف الناس من هو هذا
الشخص هو الرئيس ترامب معروف يعني لكنه
سيستغلها سياسيا وهو الذي يقول منذ اليوم
الاول بانه ضحيه لهذه المؤامرات
السياسيه من قبل الديمقراطيين وخصوصا البن
براج هذا المدعي العام المعروف في نيويورك
فقط في نيويورك قال بانه يجب ان يقاد ترم
قبل ان يعرف ما هي الاداره